[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and we got all the way down the end
we're trying to figure out where Diaz
was and Diaz popped out of the elevator
they told us very clearly don't take the
elevator don't take the elevator yeah
Joey took the elevator yeah what do you
think of my [ __ ] yeah took the
elevator like a doctor yeah like what
are you doing yeah shut the [ __ ] up
okay
yeah
San Francisco they ruined that City that
said he's never coming back
he shared a cigarette with me outside of
Cobbs and he's like he's like let me see
that cigarette I was like okay and I
gave it to him then he passed it back
and then I gave it to him again
then I go like this he goes what are you
a fat go buy a pack of cigarettes
all right you turn your nose up my three
bedroom four bath
the whole apartment just wore bathrooms
and cells
it's a [ __ ] bathroom every time I've
never seen that many bags he also pees
once a week so I don't know why he needs
so many bathrooms I mean the guy I'm
friends with 30 years I've seen him take
a piss seven times seven times just
pushing it I'm rounding up yeah I lives
in the only apartment ever seen that has
more bathrooms than bedrooms it sounds
about two bedrooms to put in a bath it's
a one bed five bath
okay when I gotta go I gotta go and I
don't like traveling far you take off
his mattress it's a bathtub under it
it's a converted tub
all right so so so I think Marshmallow
is overrated
I'm very athletic yes yeah yeah 100 yeah
yeah it's a bit people think it's a joke
100 yeah I believe it it's why it's wild
yeah but his his he knows how to harness
the
you know what I mean he's got the he has
the Hrs
hidden [ __ ] strengths
sit into you by the
because a lot of people don't know the
story you told me this story once
no you told me this story once what are
we talking about no but you told me the
story about how you were molested by a
kid with Down Syndrome man a man
mentally yeah what mentally man what are
you talking about another way yeah yeah
he was a man I think in his 20s yeah
it's quick wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait quick you
didn't get molested he asked if you want
to suck his dick and you said yes
you had to do this if you didn't do that
I'll be like what's going on and right
as right as he came Bobby's like and he
got the strength you got stronger that's
your origin story
dude it's an origin story
that's the movie
can you play Downs
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
drawn
but he's vegan he's eating only
vegetables and he looks great he looks
[ __ ] phenomenal I mean vegan would
not look good on you or me no we would
get emaciated and plus the Irish I mean
you guys are barely hanging on by a
thread anyway so I would stick to the
potatoes what was that supposed to mean
wow you guys you guys age like uh like
an old pumpkin what do you mean I'm 17.
I look fine what are you are you English
anyone else hard uh no I'm half French
half uh big [ __ ] are you oh really half a
tell I know I like some of you I'll take
the French part though what trash I know
yeah well I'm from New Orleans we're all
friends I know yeah you're all like I'm
French
is New Orleans like Australia for
England yes we're like boat French you
know swamps toothless you know we'll
hunt the gator and [ __ ] our sister and
drink a PBR I don't like the accent down
there it's that oh God that boy I hate
that [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate it yeah my
uncle's Sally you can't be a lawyer has
to talk like that yes I do declare your
honor my my client did not rape that uh
koala or whatever it is you know now I'm
doing Theo's act but
but yeah it's it's a yeah dude that used
to [ __ ] capture koalas dude he'd [ __ ]
him in front of the Town he'd [ __ ] him
right in front of the whole town dude
write this down Theo it's hard to stay
on one topic with you because you're
you're all over the buried uh he buried
Ivana on his golf course at the first
hole because he got a tax break ah I
guess one of the funniest [ __ ] is that
true I heard that you don't have to pay
taxes if it's uh a golf course or if
it's a she's right by the first place
which is also what he called her but uh
no she's right by the that's amazing wow
what a move yeah that's hilarious
is it like a lump in the grass we have
to get over like a putt-putt or it's
just like her mouth to go through to get
to the hole like those clown teeth yeah
there's a windmill in front of her mouth
but we should respect that sure dude I'm
telling you I made a assault Covenant
with myself last night no more pouring
forever
forever I don't want to ever want to
watch it ever again and it's not like
I'm not like spazzing about it it was
just born sweet dude I just I mean it's
attractive sweet as hell I don't think
you take a sweet I've been watching
sweet hold on sweet oh you hear me out
hold on this isn't the [ __ ] yes or no
the important is sweet
if you hold off for a while and you're
like oh yeah I haven't whacked off in a
while you toss on some pornography yeah
porno is sweet sure I mean again that's
like Percocets or something like that's
saying like perks are sweet like it's a
trip I've never done them I bet they're
sweet
all this [ __ ] is sweet I'm parked sweet
parks are definitely sweet as hell what
are you talking about dude perks are not
sweet I've never done a perk but I
guarantee they're Swedish I'm saying the
End Road every drug I've done ever has
been sweet as hell
there's never been a time I didn't get
[ __ ] up then I wasn't like that was
[ __ ] not sweet Percocets Percocets
are sweet cocaine's sweet [ __ ] while
you're doing it you think so
I'm thinking about End Road no so my
here's here's pornography sweet while
you're doing it yeah but maybe when
you're done when you as soon as you come
and you see what you're watching okay it
chills so say this is a fair point and I
I do say that now
say you walked up and you found your
dad's phone open with the porn he was
watching how [ __ ] sweet is it
stuck
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
dad plows fat obnoxious on his throat
your dad was whacking off to you
you told me that's sweet you're dead
whacking off to you being stuck are you
gonna make fun of Shane it would be
interesting to watch him get roasted by
his own liver
[Music]
I'm roasted Shader no that's my dog man
that's what my dog you don't have to do
it dude don't let them pit us against
each other dude that's my dog that's
exactly what the left does dude
you and I pits us against each other
dude you guys could make a movie
together it could be like white men
can't stop eating
yeah Tony you're the one who's [ __ ]
gay yeah
[Music]
Tony you look like an animal balloon
with that blue [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] yeah I
do I was wondering what this looked like
earlier and now I realized that it
looked like an animal balloon yeah
animal balloon what the [ __ ] does that
make you we like you like a blueberry
condom all right
finish him
[Music]
[Applause]
I think that you're wearing a Jordan
hoodie even though you can't get up in
the air
oh no no no that wasn't funny the only
thing you put in the air is your ass
[Applause]
stop tickling me
she keeps tickling me
this guy he wishes I haven't touched him
once
this goddamn fruitcake
I had a couple drinks I hear the little
hands yeah I touched some guys
I touched some guys sometimes it's a fun
joke
why haven't you done a product uh
because it's very interesting to me I
would think you would do a product I do
have my own line of flip-flops well
that's great yeah why not a food product
we tried to do steak sauce very tough
we'll get a four wall an ice cream shop
very tough how about do conspiracy
theory flavors of ice cream Jeffrey egg
cream
uh
um uh jet fuel doesn't melt sweet cream
crisis actor crunch with little uh crazy
because of the kids who pretended to die
um
yeah what were some of the other ones
Ben
yeah MK culture cake batter JFK batter
what was your chocolate
well there was a gulf of there was a
gulf of [ __ ] oh the Gulf of Toffee
the Gulf of toffee yeah
but you know there's so many regulations
in between black lives mother black
lives mother he said it it's this matter
well no here's here's the real bro no
here's the real brilliant one here's a
real brilliant one yeah is s'mores Floyd
that's the one that I'm sorry but that's
the one
if you edit that out send that to me for
my podcast
I was in a bar I was like yeah I was
with uh this comic Carmel gallon where
uh she's from there so she's like this
is a cool bar so we went in there and uh
some guy walked up to me and he was like
out of his mind clearly and he goes uh
he's just messing with me goes you I
could tell he's drunken [ __ ] but he
walks up and he's like University of
Vermont and I said no and he goes
master's degree and I said you're
getting colder and then he uh he goes
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you and I
was like all right and I kind of turned
away like whatever takes a pint glass
smashes it over my head and uh yeah and
I was like oh boy all right and then I
kind of I kind of get up and with a few
other people and he like stares me down
and then runs and they call the cops and
uh then the cop showed up and I'm just
trying like I'm like what do I do I'm
like let me make this funny so I think
like an Instagram story with the cops
and I'm like three more shows at the
Vermont Comedy Club you know and my mom
sees it and she goes you got assaulted
and I'm like oh yeah you follow me I
didn't know you followed me yeah yeah so
I got to I did like I'll block
true story before as he was running out
I I said you all heard him call me Jew
boy before he did it and there's a key
then
he didn't really do that I was trying to
he was a therapist the guy what they got
him yeah he was a therapists are [ __ ]
up what yeah what yeah yeah he was a
psychiatrist they they called me and
they were like do you want to press
charges I'm like well do I have to come
back and they're like yeah I'm like man
I'm good you know and then they said
well he's gonna lose his license for
five years for doing that and I was like
yeah that's weird to give people advice
when you're yeah when you're he was
blackout drunk and he was trying to I
guess his he was getting a divorce and
his wife was uh was leaving and whatever
so he you know those drunks where they
just want to get hit yeah so I think
it's like why he attacked and he was
hoping I would beat the [ __ ] out of him
he didn't count on me being a [ __ ]
but uh I did have like a a tripod with
me that was metal and I thought about
hitting him but the other part of my
head was like
then I'm gonna get in [ __ ] and also does
this guy have a gunman [ __ ] Vermont
sure so but talk about like all all like
he's going through all that and then on
top of that he's losing his life so like
now he's like he went for the cop's gun
I found out wow because like he wanted
to get shot by the cops but it's like
yeah he was like really he didn't count
on being a white guy yeah but uh you
know his white privilege really [ __ ]
him over in that uh but yeah he just
talked him down don't reach for my gun
don't wait for my gun you have the gun
give it back please you can get in a lot
of trouble for taking my gun I'm going
Australian December I think let's do
Australia
you want to do a three-man show in
Australia yes let's can we let's do that
no why that's too much that's too much
it costs like 25 Grand just to get there
give me one good reason to do it go
oh
um um um uh one good reason that we sh
all the three of us should do it in
Australia because we're friends I'll do
it
that's that's all I need to know I just
want to hear you say it and then you
maybe you can get more I think I know
what it is you want to make most of the
money yeah
so he'll be the hoodie will be the
Blowfish why not yeah yeah you be
Blowfish for the Australia I'll be
Blowfish for the Australia
that's my that's my business how long
will it work with you
give me an old man A Fine Burger
now that what the [ __ ] is going on here
[Applause]
oh my God it's the ghost of Giannis
he's doing some sort of voodoo
welcome back juice good back I liked me
time
did you really I thought it was great I
watched she says that as she's wearing
this a scissors brother's t-shirt
exactly yeah I couldn't even have one of
the worst podcasts online right now
yeah it's a cool shirt they gave it to
me for free dude we give you so much
more than they give you I just give you
so much
I've lifted your career you're coming to
SLC with me we give you merch and then
you wear their by the way that heather
gray standard issue that they got trash
yeah cheapest thing you can buy I
thought you guys liked those guys well
he's my brother yeah he's your brother
Jeremiah no the other one is my brother
the Chinese guy he's Korean yeah he's my
brother is he really Korean yeah he's my
only brother and I love him he's blood
brother he's blood brother to me wait a
minute the tiny little the little this
one the kind of look like it he's your
little brother my little brother son of
a gun yeah yeah so say something nice
whoa can I say I'm being genuine when I
ask you yeah yeah look at me huh he's
not Chinese he's not
what happens to a for you to be adopted
in your teens
so it's it's wild you know I
it's so much that ties to it but
I was a competitive cheerleader right
and this was at 15 I started
cheerleading and why what got you into
that I had a crush on this girl let's
talk about it man that's what got you in
the cheerleader that's what got me [ __ ]
yeah
guess what guess what never happened
you know
Marissa
but I can backflip okay I got that hey I
still got it it has to be Polo really
I've calculated how much I spent on Paul
am I making this up kitty no she knows
every city I go to I buy probably two or
three three packs and that comes out to
like 70 bucks right they're expensive
weekend or probably more probably 80
bucks wait why do you get them when you
travel specifically you don't pick up I
don't really yeah because when I'm on
stage I wanted to Rich guys like fresh
teas dude wait hold on step this back
you just said you don't really pack you
just kind of roll and get some [ __ ] when
you get there
is that what's happening yeah are you
going from town to town just buying
fresh gear and then moving on what do
you burn it before you leave that's the
craziest thing I ever heard that's
awesome that's my publicist right there
yeah am I lying no damn that's what this
show is all about yeah let's [ __ ] go
yo I'm not taking I'm not taking luggage
to Missouri tomorrow
I'll leave my underwear in Kansas City
[Music]
is that what this show is because I'm
confused listen we've had yes for sure
especially the successful because you
don't want to know where the the story
is yeah we do we celebrate the trash and
the classic yeah so yeah the big thing
is the is the wins as well well the
stores are are crazy I mean I probably
don't even know what they are but what
are they
do you want my publicist to tell you and
I'll look away or no you tell us
I shut down Pradas shut up really yeah
shut down you're the richest guy ever
met
that's [ __ ] awesome damn
shut him down when do you have time to
do that when you when you when you when
you say you go to yourself
dude Soho Prada loves me yeah
I didn't know you were born like that I
know you're moving some Dickies but God
damn this guy's shutting them all down
yeah they left the ball Prada all right
there's a big difference between the
[ __ ] shutting down any m's
you better not
big man likes his pretzies yeah yeah
yeah sorry no more pretzel bagels
everyone gets their parents Joe Coy with
here
that [ __ ] [ __ ] always gets here
I'm just out front goddamn jokoy [ __ ] by
the way someone gave us those Playboys
from from uh the Seinfeld episode yeah
almost in a while thumb through it I'm
like this is a great idea what tits I
mean that's a that's kind of a winner no
Playboy like I'm reading there's some
good article I got an interview with
whoever and then there's a bunch of put
like you read an article you flip the
page in this beaver and nipples you
can't lose I'm like what are we talking
about this is like the best idea ever
apparently Hugh was a little uh Rough
Around the Edges but wow he was a bad
guy he's a bad seed what do you want me
to do shoot him uh but but still I mean
Playboy bring it back a few stats to end
this best of September video samurel
made the most guest appearances this
month going on three different podcasts
followed by Rick lastman and Joe Coy who
each went on two different podcasts the
most viewed episode from this month was
bad friends going on flagrant that has
two million views although two bears 1K
featuring Joe Rogan is already up to 1.8
so we'll see how that plays out and then
just a fun fact about kill Tony from
this month it's its first ever episode
that has passed a million views on
YouTube the protect our Parks episode
with Shane Gillis Mark norm and Joe
Rogan and Ari shafir was the first time
that a kill Tony video has passed 1
million views which is honestly
surprising to me I would not have
thought that but that's something I read
on Reddit and it must be true thank you
for watching this video please subscribe
to joke World we'll come out with best
of October next month comedy news update
on Monday and a lot of good videos in
between that and then so I don't know if
that sentence made sense but I'm done
filming this thank you for watching have
a great weekend
[Music]
foreign
[Music]